have you ever been training a model only
to find that it never reaches production
well 68 to 80 percent of models that are
trained and developed never actually
make it to production well I'd like to
introduce something that that will make
training a whole lot easier for you and
your team and make deployments uh much
easier and will have much less stress
and to illustrate that I actually have a
story to give some context so my team
was uh on a crunch time with a project
with getting a model out and so we
finally got the department to approve a
GPU server for us to be able to use some
of these larger language models like
Burt and Roberta and things like that so
we got on there we started doing our
work we went as fast as we could to put
our notebooks on there we're getting
some good results we started getting
some actors some some pretty good
accuracy and we continue developing
until one day we try to SSH into the
server and we can't so only to find out
that our our department only paid for
one month on the GPU server so what
happened to all the notebooks all the uh
data all the features that we prepared
on the server
completely gone and so maybe a moment of
silence for all the notebooks that I
lost in that but
um that pretty much reflects what a lot
of manual processes what a lot of manual
training processes I mean uh look like
right now so first of all you're usually
starting out with Eda and Eda is just
exploratory data analysis can we get the
data that we need to make this model a
success so you're looking at you know uh
getting it from SQL databases or from
different teams that can give you an
export but somehow you're Gathering all
this data once you get the data you know
that the data is not ready the data has
to be prepped and so you're looking at
some time with data prep and working in
some of the gaps and seeing if anything
needs to be cleaned and from there you
might move to feature engineering we
might which might still be within the
same process uh as at the same time
you're doing your data prep and you're
creating and you're transforming some of
these
um columns and you're turning them into
new features that will help your model
well once you have the features you're
ready to train in and so training is
usually the next step training is its
own uh process it's its own pass because
you have to look into different models
you have to look and see which one's
going to give you the best accuracy
which one is most applicable to your
problem is it NLP is it a regression
um that type of thing
and the training starts once you get
some good models you also have to do the
hyper parameter optimization depending
on the model from there you're ready for
deployment
and deployment can be its own can of
worms because it's either using some
sort of API or it's got to integrate
with a front end or back end and if
you're a small team like my own you
might be the people riding both the
front end and the training
um so you're doing all of that and then
finally be ready for monitoring and
looking at how this
is performing
it's all on the deployment server
however you decided to do your endpoint
and you just got to look and see if this
accuracy is good enough for the business
but what will happen is you know entropy
eventually your model is not gonna be as
accurate as it needs to be and so this
process this whole process starts again
or your team is tasked with a new model
but all of that is manual and uh really
adds a lot of headache only for only 60
to 80 percent right only 20 is 40 to 20
percent of them actually making it to
production that's a lot of work and I'm
here to show you a different and better
way so ml Ops as you can tell from the
name implements devops principles devops
tools and devops practices into the
machine learning workflow and so the
beginning of devops in the beginning of
really any development project is you're
going to start out with uh the the the
the dev and the Eda work all of that at
the end of the day is code right you're
writing a notebook you're writing some
sort of python script or some R script
or Julia or something like that uh but
all of that is code and you can put all
of that code in a source code repository
and what that does is it opens us up for
the automation that's going to come next
so we can actually go in two directions
from our Dev and Eda looking first of
all
um the deployment
if that's an API that you're writing or
a front end or something like that
the deployment can have CI and CD tools
applied to those commits that you're
putting into your repository on the on
the other side your training
can also take benefit from CI and CD and
I'm repeating those terms but what that
means is continuous integration and
continuous deployment uh which just
means that every time you make a commit
on your repositories automatically you
can build and automatically you can you
can deploy your deployment or
automatically you can push a model to
start being trained usually if you have
uh the resources you're going to want to
separate your training infrastructure
from your deployment infrastructure and
that's because they're doing different
tasks training you're usually going to
want a GPU some sort of Highly parallel
computation and on deployment you might
be fine with spinning up Docker
containers or something uh little little
containers that might have a load
balancer to just uh handle demand but
from there both of these can benefit
from monitoring
so in devops there's naturally
monitoring tools just to make sure your
deployments are still live just to make
sure your rollouts are happening and you
can also see how a b tests are doing and
things like that we can apply the same
ideas to your model how is your model
accuracy are there things that or maybe
trigger let's say you reach 80 accuracy
which is which is too low what you can
do from that is automatically trigger a
new training process and you'll take the
code it'll begin the new training on new
data
and using CI CD and using automation you
can get a new model up on the production
server without too much hassle so just
imagine how much stress is gone from
doing this manually to going to this
automated ml Ops type of pipeline I hope
this helps and I hope that you'll be
able to see better accuracies and much
more speed whenever you're training your
models thank you
thanks so much if you like this video
and you want to see more like it please
like And subscribe and my department
said if we reach 10 000 likes they're
going to pay for another month on the
GPU server if you have any questions
please drop them in the comments below